et
en ce moment d'aller finir tous les
jours
merci à dieu merci ça merci mathieu
merci des titres ordinaires comment
passer après ça s'est impliqué c'est ce
que va dire aussi prochain
mais très d'être une
très déçu n'a pas de ne pas avoir eu ma
danse de l'amitié moi aussi avec vous si
red
bull et danser avec vous moi bon bref
cyril début d'émission exceptionnel on
commence par quoi l'habitude sa cantine
style ça c'est cosmi salut c'est parti
tout ce que vous faites pendant les pubs
pour les magnétoscopes good inside j'en
peux plus salut les loups et bienvenue
dans 50 secondes inside le pp et on
commence tout de suite avec celle qui a
remplacé isabelle daniel moreau il en
exclut nous révèle son anatomie
quasiment qu'une viande sauf le poulet
est ce que j'ai un petit trou du coup
donc j'ai trop du coup des coûts
et puis simplement bénabar a on exclut
mes audiences de tp people c'est pas
très bon signe je vois un très bel
avenir dans le domaine professionnel
si on peut être un peu mais pas dans
l'audiovisuel merde
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas une chose est sûre les fines
a peut-être été miss france mais sera
jamais mise pétrole le louvre a même
sourire c'est le port et c'est l'animal
qui se rapprochait plus de l'être humain
de sa hauteur est miné pour cent ah
ouais bah les animaux les plus
intelligents
bonjour et bienvenue dans c'est pas
sorcier salut jamie et oui peut laisser
vous l'histoire du nombre de benjamin
castaldi et oui fred c'est baba qui a la
réponse [ __ ] et des prénoms ce
lancement quand même des noms de
familles veulent dire quelque chose
comme moi rana est bas et ça veut dire
cotes données castaldi l'once est
l'ancêtre celle de son père il devait
par l'ozone
exact a dit
on continue avec matthieu delormeau
comme à son habitude le méchant il est
méchant c'est vrai c'est canaliser en
nutritionniste vous avez pris
qualité là c'est considéré comme un
fruit
tant que tu le prends pas comme
animateur
mais non mais un coup de pouce je vous y
trompez pas tous des normes n'est pas
méchant c'est juste une enflure matière
combien sera prime de départ pour ça en
jette toi vous donneriez pour qui couche
avec mon boucher avec un marche
[Applaudissements]
vous savez quelle place maudite sur pato
tmp regardez-moi ça prenne de rythme ça
n'arrête pas bougez-vous un peu la
mienne si vous deviez pas venir sur
quelqu'un j'étais en train de réfléchir
sur le plus mal habillé puisque ça
[Rires]
et puis scoop dans les pubs battu
schwinn et baba n'aime pas vraiment ça
tombe bien qu'une petite devinette telle
ou telle est l'animateur le plus sympa
que ses invités se bat bien sûr je suis
le premier à n'avoir qu'une envie c'est
de pouvoir partir en vacances au ces de
départ aller au resto
[Rires]
j'adore a hérité qu'adam le jeu là d'or
il é
ric et on adore non c'était c'est une
façon de parler non mais on imagine sur
ce constat la bonne chose sur france 2
metro par ce bras les trois
essais écrits des fois ça va ça va pas
que d'émotions vous n'êtes robichaud
encore plus qu'à l'habitude
qu'ont fait un petit une petite soirée
tous les deux
depuis combien de temps vous n'avez pas
vu une
seule une personne une farine sachez que
la gestion trouvé sa fille sexe féminin
j'avais 25 ans
pareil
ça serait beau frère a perdu de vue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça nous fait un point commun ouais c'est
vrai oui moi je me dis pourquoi ne pas
s'en mêler sa part
inconnu on y réfléchit et
on vient vers moi voilà voilà en prime
très bien et vous j'ai vu daniel vous
êtes partant à moi j'ai même pas besoin
de réfléchir à ses côtés de kate
je suis pas d'accord elle a dit non à
rio mais là d'hiver en plein de joie
c'est vrai quoi on parle a dit nora
gilles dijoux audio
fallait partager avec mes amis poilus
ouais mais sur you said inquiétez pas il
va leur en acheter ou jamais
mais comment je pourrais à we jeudi al
alam et lætitia sexuelle elle dégage
quelque chose que tu t'approches chaîne
chaleur comme ça qui est envahi
la période
et donc aux textes et moi je pourrais
tout ne serait bon alors eric daniels
vous savez je faisais du sex-appeal ah
oui c'est pas exactement c'est ça il
reste plus qu avec les pistes
[Applaudissements]
vous dites que personne est votre cas
mais ce que daniel pour elle tout comme
jordi daniel est là quelque chose on va
pas se mentir est d'accord là est là
elle a quelque chose on sent que ça
bouillonne
des gens très beau conte rien c'est ça
et parfois des gens moins faim étaient
les gens
à l'esprit des gens qui sont bien voila
voila et qui dégage vraiment quelque
chose à niel c'est un truc de fou
daniela ça oui je vous le dis à moi et
vous allez avoir de nombreux courriers à
main courrier après la chute la moyenne
non mais là je suis tête et sensuelle
ce à quoi c'est le relevé qu'ils étaient
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
compass
about espagne
c'est une question de
celtel ce n'était pas là son sermon et
est avec vous voilà d'accord sur
l'accord était par terre
d'accord allez-vous sachs a cassé la
jeunesse et le quel est selon vous où tu
as dis toi demande qu'est ce que c'est
la chesnaie
c'est une spécialité autrichien
dieter
[Rires]
tartelettes à base de poisson une tata
football
autour de septembre
[Applaudissements]
oui
mais bon j'aime et respecte à
14h autour de cette table qui sait le
rouet comme le h2 hanouna et sert à rien
alors je ne peux pas le dire tout ils
servent aussi à la la la la j'adore tout
le monde bénévoles aime ton masque
j'ai maintenant
la bonne réponse mais vous dites que
vous aimez to book mais regardez magnéto
qui va supporter ans n'est pas le cas
on découvre ce trio là on est content ça
qu'on a cessé de l'année télévision ça
alors combien ces d'années d'échecs ça
c'est ton meilleur lit pour est à
gratter dans cette fille est inclus dans
les loges excusez moi jackie et michel
[Rires]
un
frémissement tour tutoie juste comme ça
drôle mais je tente quand astérix ne
voudrait voir le secret de beauté de
chacun mais bien entendu chez il fera
pas cette série
je tends des dominés thibault elle sera
la wii non elle finit l'émission je
pense que je pourrais la libérer 19h45
buffalo gris qu'appelez vous attendent à
leur
mercie 1 et la situe alors le festival
de la magie celle
ci les membres adorent
ces deux un pote avec un but vraiment il
est très intelligent
castaldi conapp entendu des lignes non
moi je trouve
en fait nous nous ici pour vous vous
habillez vous faire quoi vous
[Rires]
de retour à cette semaine dans touche
pas à mon poste nicolas pernikoff vous
le verrez il sera au troisième rang
vous n'êtes pas pour retrouver une vie
normale mais parce que je crois que vous
le masque que vous arrange
[Applaudissements]
tu seras une star quand tu auras fait
huit cent mille téléspectateurs sur tf1
des dépôts va la tenter de merde
ça fait ch ou de l'amitié
vous savez comme je vous aime qui aime
bien châtie bien ou ne savait donc je
vous aime vraiment beaucoup c'est vrai
que depuis le début de l'année je suis
un peu un fouteur de tahoua si bien et
j'aime bien [ __ ] le bordel et donc la
semaine dernière j'avais monté benjamin
castaldi quand matthieu delormeau et
bien cette semaine j'ai décidé de le
faire un peu le bazar et je me suis
inspiré d'une émission qu'on adore cyril
et que beaucoup de téléspectateurs
doivent adorer c'est la radio libre de
difool sur skyrock d'harmonie foule
d'amour ils ont une séquence ils ont
même risque aussi de
séquences oui bien sûr
une séquence qui s'appelle le double
appel alors pour les téléspectateurs qui
ne connaissent pas le double appel c'est
on prend deux téléphones et on ne fait
rien si les malins écouter difool 6 or
ni c'est incroyable on laisse parler et
là on l'a fait mais pas avec des
inconnus ont la fecq des guest est ce
que vous les avoirs le sommaire qu on a
raymond avec bertrand des classes on à
momo de koh lanta avec jean messier
enfin et on a si luis ortega avec dans
les faits datent en heure
alors j'ai rien compris mais ça a l'air
super
t
[Musique]
andré site chauffer remo avec bertrand
dekkers relâchés on va essayer de copies
de maintenant s'il vient dégâts et afida
turner on y sera on passe un statut
allô
[Musique]
d'accorder quatre minutes dans la vie
alors je vais te dire en toi tu vas
encore 8 octobre et puis après quelqu'un
d'autre ok je livrais du savon pour se
laver la bouche si tu sais du club nous
avons fait en sorte de voyage dans le
temps en ont un débat dans plus de 40
banques
[Musique]
n'ont pas de couilles au cul on zappait
l'époque pas parler
[Applaudissements]